hi I'm Sam grub art i'm here at
samsung's unpacked event in new york and
this is the Galaxy Note edge now first
this might look like just another
samsung tablet but check this out the
screen curves off the edge of the device
now why in the world would you need a
curved display like that while samsung
says so that you can access frequently
used apps and functions as well as a
ticker-tape of information and photos
now no pricing or availability has been
made public yet however Samsung is
saying that they're going to have an SDK
kit for developers to take advantage of
this new panel like other Samsung
tablets it does use the S Pen Stylus
which allows you to operate the phone
like with a mouse and draw and paint and
do whatever else you might do with
something like this I've never quite
understood it this is one way that
Samsung is demonstrating how it has
certain leadership capabilities in the
market that its competitors don't
samsung is the primary manufacturer for
displays around the world for
smartphones tablets and other devices
and this is a bit of a showpiece to show
how far ahead they are from the rest of
the competition